you know him from magic mike 21 jump
street and possibly that sexy dream you
had last night that's right that's right
give it up for channing tatum everybody
[Music]
hello hi how are you i am so good but
you look
like somewhere wonderful behind you i i
want to be where you're at oh yeah
yeah that looks awesome come on over we
should just do this
it looks like i want to take a walk in
your garden or your park behind you i
don't know what's happening
but what did you think because you're
such a fitness guy what did you think of
meg's fitness story it's pretty
incredible right
unreal i mean look i as someone that has
to work out as for a job i
i promise you i would not look like this
unless i had to be naked in most of my
movies
mostly and like at some point i gotta
get better at acting so i don't have to
be naked in all of them
but she is just incredible i i really
i mean i literally get to work out as a
job
and it is and it's still hard and i
can't imagine people
that have have a nine-to-five job have
kids at home
and then where do they get the energy
and the time to to actually like
you know focus on themselves and i just
think it's really beautiful what she's
doing
absolutely and you get it your dad this
like there's a lot of time like just for
work and then you're a dad
it's like it's a lot like to fit
everything in um
so do you do you do like massive cheat
days because
dwayne um johnson was on here and he
showed me his cheat day and i was like
first of all i would barf if i ate all
the things he ate
but do you have massive ones i i
sometimes do
uh not like not like massive ones
because i think as i'm getting older
it's really getting
like everything i pick up i just go oh
that's like two more miles that i have
to run a ride and
and it's like i just start looking at
things like they're just
actual miles in time that i have to work
out so
i will pick the days and i will pick
very specific things i love cake
but uh but yeah it's oh my god and you
just had a birthday we have birthdays
near each other i'm the 24th and you're
the the 26th right
of april of course man we are absolutely
running the world yeah i just just had
it just had it i don't know one taurus
that doesn't love cake i'm just saying
lester's birthday is today and he loves
k i'm just saying but he
is that a cake thing is that a tourist
thing i i think so i'm owning it i'm
claiming it it's not my fault i was born
into this
i was um so how did you celebrate
uh we really did like we chilled i mean
i think even
during quarantine like last year it was
just a really chill sort of birthday and
and we just sat around the pool we
we sidewalked chalked uh my my driveway
we have a giant wolf that looks like
it's
uh we traced all the all the light
shadows from the trees and it looks like
this wolf's on fire it's like a wolf
walker on firewolf
that has like chicken legs for some
reason i don't know why i think we i
think neither one of my
daughter or i knew how to draw a wolf
feet so we just went with chicken
oh my gosh have you seen the thing on
netflix i think it's called like
wolf walker or something it's like my
kids were obsessed with it i can't
remember the name of it but it won all
these awards
it was so good but it's so good that
yeah yeah that's that's our favorite
movie at the moment
same same filmmaker as uh song of the
sea which you should definitely see the
music and it is just
outstanding oh wow i started watching
one last night with my kids and i was
like is this the same
the same people that made the wolf one
and anyway i've seen it so many times
um but is it is it true though that your
first big challenge with fatherhood was
learning how to braid hair
yeah i completely panicked when i found
out we were having a girl and i
literally went to youtube and started
figuring out like
how like i think the first one i saw was
a dad vacuuming up his
his daughter's hair with like a hair tie
onto the vacuum and i was like
that's genius and then it doesn't work
like the guy did it i tried it and it
didn't work as well
but yeah so i learned how to braid hair
i'm the hardest thing though
because my daughter has really straight
fine hair i have to do this every night
or she wakes up with a rat's nest it
doesn't it's like a giant like
knot back there um but the hardest thing
because she has layered hair
is doing the three close to the head
equal strands
yeah you know like that once once i got
that the braiding is easy the rating's
really really simple but i always
i'll get like three or a third of the
way through and i'll realize that one
strand is a lot shorter than the other
one and my ocd kicks in and i have to
like restart
and then it's just terrible i know god
bless sports for me on that one we all
used to braid each other with volleyball
and soccer all those sports we i learned
that at a very young age
his new children's book is called the
one and only sparkle and it's out right
now
um but have you always wanted to write a
kids book cause i i
didn't think one i'd ever have a kid and
then i had kids and then i was like
oh it'd be fun to write a book you know
you're reading them all the time with
your kids and i ended up doing it too is
that kind of how it happened for you
um sort of i mean i never thought i'd be
an author of anything
much less like a kid's book and but like
what you're saying you know you
definitely end up reading
almost all of them you know you were
looking for any suggestions because we
read five books every night we
like all my all my friends were like you
read five that was a horrible idea
why didn't you just say it's one book
and i was like it's too late we started
we started with five already it's
it's not the guy is cast so we were
reading
everything under the sun and you know
and then i definitely realized that
there weren't that many
dad daughter books um there was a kind
of a hole in the market there there was
a lot of mom
kid books and certain other ones and and
i just sort of was like you know i don't
know i wanted to write something that
was very you know just me and my
daughter have a really beautiful
relationship and it's really
fun and you know i was worried you know
i was worried a little bit of just how
being a dad of how was i going to relate
and
understand a little girl and and the key
was just to go into her world
and it was so fun and the world that we
created was so rich
and like the characters and the voices
and the things was so much fun and she's
such a little character that
i don't know i just the story just sort
of happened
like i i didn't really have to like dig
deep for the imagination it was more
just observing my daughter and like and
really just our relationship is super
hilarious to me
yeah it's if you are anything like the
father in that book you're awesome and
you're nailing it
it was amazing too like how you were
coming and and
my kids loved it they left they were
like i wonder if daddy would dress up
and
their dad probably totally would but it
was just like they it totally got their
minds thinking
like you said there's not a lot of debt
i really can i thought i was thinking
nelly knew that from the llama llama
series there's only one book that's kind
of with the dad and they paint this
whole thing
but other than that i was like i don't
really know of any so it's a really good
idea and it's so important because
father figures are so important for kids
and i loved spark ella and i loved that
she went with the she tried to fit in
and then she comes back
my kids i mean they're hard on books we
read every night just like you
apparently and
they're hard on books and they will just
walk away they'll be like i'm done
i just want to go to bed like they're
they can be hard on authors
like i'm like you're a critic but they
loved it and they were captivated the
whole time
and you did a really good job with it
thank you that means that means a lot to
me i mean we
you know it was and and these are the
same way she really is hard on books
she's hard even on me when i was little
like
when she was little i would read and all
the i was trying so hard to be
entertaining and
and doing all the voices and everything
and
she'd be like dad can you just read it
straight just
i just want it straight and i'm like
i've been training for this my whole
life and you don't want me to do the
voices
yeah you didn't like my english accent
yeah exactly i was like look i'm never
gonna do an english accent in the movie
let me do it with you
okay
but uh but yeah i don't know she's i i i
totally
i totally gave you yeah he's a he's a
hard critic and she
like the like the glitter poop and stuff
like that we
really do that and she found it really
funny my kids were cracking up my little
boy was cracking up at glitter poop he
was like you said poop
um he's five um but but anyways so
is your daughter anything like are you
like the characters do you are y'all
that sparkle is she
all that kind of sparkle rock and roll
little girl walking in yeah you know
there was a there was a really kind of
where the where the whole
uh genesis of the story was she was in
preschool and she had this like
she had this like watermelon cape sort
of thing that when you held your arms
out
it looked like she was a slice of
watermelon but like when it was down she
just looked like a cool little cape
and i remember she loved it i don't even
know where we got it i don't remember
buying it
and she loved it and i remember the day
that she put it on to go to school and
then when i was like all right
all right babe it's time to go let's go
she like panicked and i was like she
started taking it off she's like i don't
want to wear it i don't wear it and then
and then i was like wait what's what's
wrong and and i and she's like i don't
want to get made fun of
and i was like and i realized the very
that was like the very first time
at least that i saw of her being like
self-conscious about like
how other people saw her or real and it
was like heartbreaking but you know
a beautiful moment all in one but she
really did she like that was like a
small phase and she really did come out
of
any kind of um i think
self-consciousness in a way like she's a
little precocious little trickster
and she's very much like sparkle and i
don't know i i really
maybe i like to wear a fuchsia boa a
little too easily maybe i like to think
my nails are a little too easy
i'm not sure okay but it's awesome
[Laughter]
it's fun anything that make her laugh
it's a good idea
i love it i love it it really is a good
thing for dads too it's a really cool
thing you're doing so what
i have a question did you my mom is an
educator so like we read a lot when i
was a kid
did your parents do the same for you is
that why you read a lot with her
uh yeah my mom my mom read a lot my dad
worked a lot
um i'm on work too but i think i
remember my mom reading
most with me and they still they kept
all my books
uh they all like the you know the golden
uh spine the golden spine i can't know
yeah yeah my daughter got to read them
so it was really cool i was like
it was such a a bizarre sort of trip
through memory lane to like
open up a book that you probably didn't
see or read and
like the last time you were you were
probably eight or seven yeah and to get
to now do it at 40 was like a really
strange
like trip but um but yeah i think they
did they did
they they were at a good bit are there
any like
lessons like i don't know are things
advice that your parents gave you that
you are gonna pass on to everly
uh i i gotta figure out how to do this
one in a little maybe different of a of
a way but i but i love the message
uh my mom my mom um put
the my mom and dad would like kind of
draw little cartoons on my on my lunch
box napkin
uh when i was when i was little and my
mom drew this one or maybe i think she
printed it out and put it in
but it was like a comic from like the
newspaper and it was this guy
uh in in like a coffin sorry it's not
this morbid i promise
uh it's a guy in a coffin like holding a
rose and he looks like pristine and he's
got he's in the suit and
and the the line i think above it or
is you don't want to reach the grave in
a well-preserved body and the next
the next frame is is like a
like a coffin and a guy looking like
he's sliding in sideways and he looks
happy and blissed out
but he's all like roughed up and he's
like you want to slide in sideways going
what a ride and uh and i you know i
definitely
i definitely subscribe to that maybe a
little too hard i think
my uh my body is definitely paying for
it in old range um
but i i definitely like learn from from
her and and from my dad to
you know anything you do do it at 100
miles per hour and enjoy it as much as
you possibly can
and that's the thing i really want to
teach evie is just how to live
how to live and how to have fun and find
joy yeah not live in fear and really
live every moment fully and be present
that's that's awesome advice
well it is lovely to see you channing
good luck on the boat it's amazing
i'm such a fan of you i just want you to
know like i'm i'm so happy
like that you're doing this and people
are getting you i'm like a real fan
you're such a good big heart ditto i've
been dancing with you in those movies
for a minute
um i wish i could say i've been singing
with you but
i ain't doing that well now
because the worst people at karaoke are
always my favorite
all right well everybody be sure to grab
channing's new kids book it's called the
one and only spark ella it's out right
now your kids are gonna love it i
promise
yup i'm still here just waiting for you
to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever help